[Musique]
là messieurs bonsoir 21 décembre premier
jour de l'hiver premiers jours de
vacances pour les enfants et qu'on le
veuille ou non
l'esprit de noël souffle un peu partout
sur l'actualité cette fête est l'otage
du polisario là passeront en famille
begin et sadate la passe font ensemble à
ismaïlia en egypte ce qu'il y a deux
mois pour être paru impensable
un autre coup de chapeau maintenant à
michel platini la vedette du club de
football de nancy qui vient de convoler
avec christelle bigoni du nord
ravissante rousse aux yeux bleus
étudiante à nancy ça se passait il y à
quelques heures à saint max dans la
banlieue nancéienne la rédaction
d'antenne 2 présente ses voeux de
bonheur aux jeunes de le faire à cause
du cassiot c'est que voilà et le bon
cher professeur jour des savoir si au
niveau du groupe il existait possibilité
après tirman de quelques corollaire
c'est de quelques à porter à ébullition
plus jouèrent betty qui entraînerait une
fragmentation prague bête
franchement c'est pas la peine de
prendre des cours chez moi pour faire ça
à part vous plaire écoute je voulais
tragédien pour moi je voulais que ce
soit que me dire mais là là tu n'es rien
du tout mais rien du tout 00 naruse
c'est le chou fleur se joue tous les
soirs au théâtre la bruyère qui m'a
rendu fou de toi c'est une seule fois en
dix jours
nous nous sommes embrassés en normandie
le mardi le quatrième jour quelle
mémoire sont pas donner mes impressions
ben maintenant l'avouent le poney comme
ça l'a fait ce que je dois vous dire que
j'ai un plaisir immense à jouer
c'est une mascarade je ne suis pas une
mascarade je suis poli ton cousin je
vaux bien mais qu'est ce que tu fais là
j'ai changé de maison avec léonard comme
qu'il désirait je n'ai jamais voulu ça
mais si tu l'as dit qu'il fallait qu'on
soit dans ton jardin mais c'est un
minimum
avec l image une façon de parler et puis
tu m'énerves à la fin bon je crois que
c'est le moment de mettre la musique
tous ça va le mettre de bonne humeur
allez
[Musique]
fall sur l'épée
mathieu fleury
[Musique]